Jack Zack imagine someone put five-pound
ball underneath that stick
[Music]
so today we are trying on boob weights
not big boobs but weights that simulate
the weight of big food there's a viral
video that came out that featured men
wearing weights on their chest so that
company sent us their boob weights so we
can try it out too I have chronic back
problems already actually I can't
imagine how that would be impacted with
weights on my chest you have large boobs
we do what's that like I think it's
amazing but it's also a freaking
headache I feel like my posture is down
there's nothing worse than having
extreme back pain and then this bra like
sitting on it and I literally will go to
bathroom sometimes I'm like massage my
shoulders so today we're gonna try
things like exercising normal chores
just live our daily lives - on your
chest is going to feel heavy and it's
going to feel awkward I know my wife's
boobs really well I also have a sister I
don't know her sis as well
good morning beautiful good morning
so the try guys slept over at my house
and now we're gonna try on some boobs
our breasticles Tatas are te enablers oh
right oh I mean they're a lot like
testicles wait how much do they weigh
though oh that's not that much look at
them go look at my boobs go no if this
is supposed to be a fun video but it's
fun right now there can only be three
days before you become an ass f what
happened to you
there is no e oh no like my first
thought is these need support and that
price doubles - yeah you're browsing
more expensive they're falling to the
side I want you guys to go inwards and
upwards strapless doesn't work for me
now I can it just sits on top of us
already I'm feeling just like a little
bit of a pull we'll see what I say at
the end of the day but right now I don't
think this is too much weight I just
want you guys to just go through the
motions
day all right let's go clean up Ned's
house all right zakir to do some yard
work boo gonna start with dishes are you
gonna put on pants ever or no I got fake
boobs a real booty doing the dishes was
tough because bending over the boobs are
kind of swinging around me on the other
hand I learned a pretty cool new trick
what a great time just having a giant
pendulum this rate of wreak havoc is
like if you turn too fast it's like you
have to be aware of this extra weight of
your body Oh certainly the constant
strain is something my body isn't you
see if I get I'm fitting Zac do your
chores not my yard and this yard is
built II you know I've met treat this
yard this way you deserve to have a
messy yard don't swing Zack Zack we're
working Zack it's making Zack a very
grumpy and he's already a little whiny
baby it was when we were about to clean
the toilet that my boobs broke Oh what
was that
so net put on a bra and I said [ __ ] it
I'm put on a bra to most stores don't
sell my bra size so I have to actually
buy like a different bra size that's
close to my bra size but it's not my bra
size so it won't fit right and like my
boobs won't sit right it's weird that
the pain has changed us now it's not
pulling down but it's like digging in
here can you imagine having these heavy
boots and this bra that's like digging
into your shoulder it just distributed
the pain it's just everywhere now
so I walk into lunch yeah two of us are
in bras two of us are without teeth and
I decided to keep our breasts free
because we're just those free-spirited
types at one point I had to run across
the street to catch a light oh yeah I
run like this you what I like you like
and God when you run your boobs are just
bouncing so much going all sorts of ways
of holding them I just like I
instinctively grabbed my babies Saten
put my boobs on the table in the past
hour I start to get like just like a lot
of like tightness here every time I roll
my neck I get like some pretty intense
cracks lunch was great it was
rejuvenating but I got some crumbs down
my bra nothing has really bothered me
yet but I know we're about to go work
out at a gym and I know that's when most
women with large breasts sight really
terrible inconveniences so we're at the
gym we're gonna work out I'm going to do
poorly I just want to say ahead of time
that the boobs are not the reason why
have you ever gone to the gym and left
your sports bra at home yeah I can't
work out me too we're gonna try it a
little bit without a sports bra and then
we're gonna try it with a sports bra to
work out with you when you're jumping
it's a weight appear and if it's not
supported it's like pulling on the front
of your chest you feel it all up in here
because it's literally ready back your
back to pull back it's really starting
to hurt this morning it was shoulders
and neck and now my like my mid back my
lower back
we need a sports bra you team yeah is
this a disaster okay it's time for
sports bras these do feel more secure
it's not comfortable normal boobs are
squishy goodness this is rocky shitness
yeah it's rocky shitness the classic
term once was enough so we're gonna go
to well they're definitely in place now
so a little bit better let's do it
[Music]
can I have another please well then I'm
just gonna can I just okay
my throat's not gonna get punched come
to mommy
give me some sugar oh yeah this is a lot
safer business just way easier
definitely function over fast I can see
why if you forgot your sports bra you
would go home if you don't have a sports
bra and your large breasted you can't do
this we're back at the office and for
the rest of the day we're just gonna be
doing our normal job a lot of desk work
a lot of answering emails and we're
gonna see how the boobs affect us here
also Eugene and I are now wearing bras
so everybody's supported
doing desk work isn't the most difficult
thing in the world it's just that after
you spent your whole day working and
then sitting at a desk for several hours
just hunched over it just sort of
compounds the problems that you've been
gave it's probably the worst of it for
me because I have all of this weight on
the front and it's not even doubt on the
back and I've definitely thought of
getting a reduction because of that back
pain at the time of my breast reduction
I was a 30 GG like George and I was a
dancer growing up had the body very
skinny 810 pounds and then all of a
sudden I had double G's on my chest
medically I had like terrible terrible
headaches live real serious have a
headache this whole day has been just
slowly more and more I had to go to a
chiropractor all the time just because
of my back and like my upper shoulders
my neck I just I can't do it anymore I'm
just I'm just over it normal everyday
things like finding clothes that fit me
or finding bathing suits or cute Brides
was impossible this bra is killing me
more than the weights and I think it's
because it's just not correctly sized
your underwire bothering here oh yeah
it's like it's all bothering me every
time I straighten up my whole back
cracks and that's not normal for me I
think three pounds or seven pounds
sounds like that much but when you're
wearing it on your chest for 24 hours a
day and you have to do normal things or
jump around or anything anything really
it makes a huge difference I'm so sorry
mom I'm so sorry sisters for anything
bad I ever said about boobs
can we go when you get home that bra
comes off you are like oh oh oh oh my
God look if the large chested woman is
ever like short with you and seems a
little pissy I'm just gonna say [ __ ]
take it because you have no idea what
she's going through you don't know what
kind of back pain headache she may have
some people's boobs are a huge burden to
their life so it's not so simple as like
a face value appreciation I can't
imagine if this was on my bare breasts
all day all I hear about is that bras
are not correctly sized across the board
that's a real problem fashion industry
don't just appreciate the boobs
appreciate the person behind the boobs
it's a struggle sometimes you know but I
love my boobs they make me feel sexy and
beautiful for young women growing up who
maybe aren't so comfortable with your
body that you have options and you
deserve to feel really good about
yourself it's about what makes you feel
also that's really at the end of the day
is to open people's eyes we love you
girls we do also the whole broad thing
how I who designed to think you can't
look at I don't what am I supposed to do
where does it even begin or end you know
how you zip your pants here if I just
have my pants on my plant I'd be furious
[Applause]
[Music]